quanti di voi hanno perso per strada il
proprio sogno
io sono felice io amo il mio lavoro
tre frasi hanno caratterizzato la mia
vita fino ad oggi la prima fare ciò che
ami e libertà amare ciò che fai e
felicità amare ciò che fai e felicità io
amo il mio lavoro e per questo sono
felice
il mio lavoro ha come protagonista il
circo ho incontrato il circo per la
prima volta a 8 anni
nello stesso modo in cui molti bambini
di 8 anni incontrano il circo per la
prima volta
mio nonno mi portò a vedere il circo che
in quei giorni era nel mio piccolo paese
in provincia di novara
appena entrato nel tendone rimasi
letteralmente affascinato ricordo ancora
i numeri dei giocolieri le evoluzioni
degli acrobati ricordi colori le luci
ricordo ancora il profumo dello zucchero
filato e dei pop corn quel giorno il
circo è entrato ufficialmente per la
prima volta nella mia vita
quel giorno il circo entrato per la
prima volta nei miei sogni
iniziai le scuole medie durante gli anni
delle scuole medie internet e più
precisamente youtube divennero la mia
vera e propria finestra sul mondo grazie
a internet
ho iniziato ad approfondire il discorso
circo
ho iniziato a conoscere le diverse
discipline le diverse tecniche
ho conosciuto persone guardavo
spettacoli
insomma dedicavo il mio tempo libero a
giocare a guardare il circo guardavo il
circo mi appassionavo al mondo del circo
durante gli anni delle scuole superiori
il circo per me da gioco diventa una
vera e propria passione
nello specifico mi appassiono alle
tecniche di giocoleria e nella mia
cameretta da autodidatta iniziò a
giocare a fare il giocoliere
sempre negli stessi anni sempre grazie a
internet
scopro vengo a conoscenza del cirque du
soleil il circo per eccellenza il circo
con la c maiuscola si russo lei una
compagnia di circo canadese nata alla
fine degli anni 80 e si distingue dagli
altri circa perché è stato uno dei primi
a non utilizzare gli animali nei suoi
spettacoli in quegli anni la critica gli
desse pochi mesi di vita perché il circo
senza animali in quegli anni non poteva
far fortuna ad oggi siriu soleil e la
compagnia di circo e spettacolo più
grande al mondo vanta oltre 5.000
dipendenti e all'attivo più di 25
spettacoli itineranti in tutto il mondo
una voce dentro di me mi disse se mai un
giorno
riuscirai a lavorare con il circo dovrai
lavorare per quel circo in camera mia
con le palline stavo iniziando a
diventare bravino ero bravo a far girare
le palle
quindi il passo da lì è stato breve mi
dissi perché non trasformare questa tua
passione questo tuo gioco in un lavoro
perché non vivere grazie alla giocoleria
wow presi coraggio andai dalla mia
famiglia
premessa nessuno nella mia famiglia a
che fare col mondo del circo o dello
spettacolo presi coraggio andai da mio
papà e da mia mamma
avevo da poco finito gli esami di
maturità gli dissi papà mamma io voglio
fare una scuola di circo esattamente due
mesi dopo ero ufficialmente iscritto a
ingegneria meccanica ma era
ufficialmente iscritto a ingegneria
meccanica ingegneria meccanica per far
felici le persone che avevo tournament
ci rimasi comunque tre anni ed ieri 30
esami
sempre in quel periodo attorno a me
volavano frasi come guarda che col circo
non si mangia
guarda che forse uno su mille ce la fa e
mi dissero anche cosa pretendi tu che
vieni da questo paesino nella provincia
di novara cosa pretende di arrivare alla
corte del cirque du soleil
in quel periodo
benny lessi una seconda frase
focalizzati su un obiettivo e
trasformati in quello che pensi
trasformati in quello che pensi pensa al
circo e diventerai circo
mi sono detto con una massiccia dose di
coraggio lascia ingegneria meccanica
iniziarono anni veramente duri
iniziai a studiare seriamente e ad
allenarmi seriamente frequenta un corso
di teatro e giocoleria in una scuola in
svizzera e in una scuola torino presi
una laurea breve in scienze motorie
applicate al circo sociale
all'università di tor vergata di roma mi
allenai molto studiai molto ma la sfida
più grossa per me in quel periodo non è
stata lasciare ingegneria meccanica
la grande sfida per me è stata entrare
in un mondo a me completamente nuovo gli
esami di ingegneria meccanica non li
vedevo come delle grandi sfide
le grandi sfide per me erano altre era
imparare a far girare bene tre palline e
poi imparare a farne girare 4 e poi 5
non vi sto a raccontare tutte le porte
in faccia le delusioni e i sacrifici che
ho dovuto sopportare in quel periodo vi
racconta invece che insieme a tre amici
nell'estate 2011 abbiamo aperto la prima
scuola di circo a novara la scuola di
circo di mm per far conoscere il circo
alla città di novara e per avere uno
spazio dove poterci allenare e dove
poter creare i nostri spettacoli nel
settembre 2011
mi si presenta la mia prima grande
opportunità
scopro che da lì a pochi giorni cirque
du soleil sarebbe stato a milano per
cercare dei nuovi artisti per cercare
delle nuove persone da inserire in
spettacoli già esistenti con sempre la
mia bella dose di coraggio e aggiungo
anche un po di faccia tosta
mi presento ai provini del cirque du
soleil quel giorno si russo lei mi disse
no data male ok mentre tornavo a casa
però ero contento prima cosa ero
riuscito anche se per pochissimi secondi
a sfiorare il mio grande amore è
riuscito a sfiorare il serious solenne e
poi a quel no quel giorno
seguì una motivazione mi dissero no
perché sei troppo giovane dentro di me
quel sei troppo giovane
risuona come un arrivederci e non comune
addio
tornai a casa più carico ancora più
determinato ancora più aggrappato al mio
sogno
seguirono 3 duri anni fatti di
allenamento e studio e soprattutto non
persi mai di vista il mio obiettivo non
persi mai di vista il mio sogno
esattamente tre anni dopo nell'ottobre
scopro per caso e sottolineo per caso
che cirque du soleil
il giorno dopo sarebbe stato nuovamente
a milano per cercare degli artisti da
inserire uno spettacolo nuovo unico
esclusivo cancello i miei impegni e mi
precipito a milano dopo sette ore di
provino la regista dello spettacolo mi
disse marco welcome in del cirque du
soleil family e di solito qua scatta un
applauso spontaneo yes
bravi
ok complimenti per la spontaneità le
cose migliori non si programmano
succedono le cose migliori non si
programmano succedono ce l'avevo fatta
ero entrato nella famiglia del cirque du
soleil
avevo finalmente raggiunto il mio sogno
da lì a pochi giorni
iniziò a lavorare allo spettacolo alla
vita spettacolo scelto dal cirque du
soleil per essere rappresentato ogni
sera durante expo milano 2015
lo spettacolo è stato visto da oltre
320.000 persone e nello specifico io
ricoprivo la parte di leo il bambino
protagonista dello spettacolo al termine
rese al termine di alla vita al termine
del mio primo lavoro col sito su lei mi
sono detto marco ami il tuo lavoro
sì sei felice si hai raggiunto il tuo
sogno si vuoi fermarti no raggiunto il
mio sogno raggiunto il mio obiettivo
me ne sono subito posti degli altri
voglia di migliorarsi voglia di
continuare mai fermarsi settimana
prossima sarò a londra con un tour di
spettacoli da settembre inizierò un
nuovo spettacolo in belgio mai fermarsi
due sono i pensieri
al termine di alla vita il primo secondo
me se non avessi incontrato tutti gli
ostacoli che ho incontrato sul mio
percorso
forse non avrei tirato fuori così le
unghie per aggrapparmi con tutte le mie
forze al mio sogno al mio obiettivo
a volte secondo me una strada troppo in
discesa non aiuta una strada in salita
ti fa apprezzare di più la fatica questa
non l'avevo preparata all'uscita
così il secondo questo ne sono
pienamente convinto quel bambino che
vent'anni fa ha iniziato a sognare
insieme al suo nonno sotto il tendone
quel bambino non ha mai perso per strada
il suo sogno
vi invito a rispolverare il vostro sogno
nel cassetto
il futuro appartiene a coloro che
credono nella bellezza dei propri sogni
grazie